there's a new brand on the scene called
alif they make hundred percent halal raw
cat food there are countless health
benefits to this new raw diet check them
out on instagram at alif dot uk they do
monthly subscription boxes and you can
get 10 discount on their two week trial
box with my code ali10 check them out
now and let your cat enjoy some nice
food
brothers and sisters and dear friends
johnny depp he said something which i
was like wow if he said this in a bit of
a tweet way in islam it's actually a
mages it's
really haram he said the following you
start to slowly realize that you are in
a relationship
with your mother
in a sense and hello guys so before i
start obviously guys as you guys know
with muslim aid i'm trying to raise five
hundred thousand meals in china we're
nearly close to our target please please
check the link in the description box
below and donate whatever you can
inshallah let's get on with this video
but he said basically that he used to
get abuse from his mom when he was young
physically getting beaten up et cetera
and at one moment he says you know what
i felt like i was married to my mother
you know um and i had to check with my
teachers et cetera it doesn't fall into
what is mentioned in surah al jazeera
now in suramar guys allah is talking
about a woman whose
um
like what he said if he was worded like
this it can be haram actually you know
islamically as muslim men we are not
allowed to say the statement that you
are like the back of my mother meaning
i see you like my mother i know i don't
want ever any relationship with you this
is something really really similar to
what johnny depp said if he was tweaked
a bit in the right way the intentions
that if he was a muslim this is actually
haram to say and you know what allah
says in the quran there's a whole story
but it's about a woman actually this is
very profound that came to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
complained about her husband that she
said something he said something that
was really heartbreaking to her that he
he just said something like he said you
were like the back of my mother and that
was so hurtful to her when she came
there was no revelation and the prophet
peace be obviously tried to advise her
the best she he can and when she left
the revelation came down and look what
allah said to the defense of the woman
and similar to what johnny depp said but
not exactly
certainly allah has heard the speech of
the woman who argues pleading with you
muhammad concerning her husband and
directs her complaint to allah and allah
hears your dialogue indeed allah is all
hearing or seeing those who pronounce
zehar amongst you to separate from their
wives meaning saying you are like the
back of my mother they are not your
their mothers their mothers and men but
those who gave birth to them and indeed
they are saying an objectional statement
and falsehood but indeed allah is
pardoning and forgiving and those who
pronounce say that
that you are like the back of my mother
from their wives and then wish to go
back on what they said so if they said
something and they want to now take
their wife back for intimacy and
whatever it may be allah says
no you cannot do that
unless then they must be the thing of a
slave before they teach before they
touch one another so the man has to free
a slave
that is the way of adminis and
admonished thereby and allah is aware of
what you do so now this man didn't have
a slave the woman said look my husband
doesn't have a slave to give the next
one the next kind of punishment and if
he does not have a slave then fast two
consecutive months that man has to fast
two months plus ramadan three months for
the word that he uttered before they
touch one another and then the woman
said look my husband's old if he fussy
and he's gonna die and he said and who
is that if he's unable then he should be
feeding 60 poor people and then the
woman said
he's broke he doesn't have the money
that some narration didn't say that she
ended up paying on his behalf yeah that
is for you to believe completely in
allah and his messenger and those are
the limits set by allah and for the
disbelieve is a painful punishment so
guys you can see here clearly
subhanallah
how some people accuse your muslim man
you know apparently i'll come home i
have a big stick and i go to my wife i
see that stick i'm gonna beat you with
that stick and we treat our wives very
badly you know here's a verse coming to
defend the right of a woman and saying
why because i a man hit her punched her
slapped her swore at her no just because
he said you are like the back of my
mother
and look at all these free
things that's mentioned for you for a
man to do as a punishment
and i thought what johnny depp said kind
of related to this that's what i wanted
to say how beautiful islam is that gives
a right to the woman based on what she
needs and the right to a man based on
what he needs so next time
if you want to
watch the full video uh with me uh
discussing johnny depp and amber's
situation of conflict and what the quran
says check the next video inshallah may
allah bless you guys